Okay, let's talk about this.
So first of all,
a lot of us stay at home moms don't have rich husbands
we could cause we sacrifice and we make it happen.
You'd literally be surprised how many costs you can cut
and how many things you can,
like, sacrifice.
You literally be surprised.
There's like so much talk about, like,
how we're privileged,
oh my gosh, you're so lucky.
There's so much talk about that,
but what people don't know is,
is that we're determined to give our children
a better life that we had.
There's just choices you gotta make.
Because I knew I wasn't gonna be the mom
dropping off my baby at daycare.
I just knew that wasn't gonna be me.
I, so I prioritized.
There's a lot of things you can cut costs on
and do so you guys can live off one income.
And I know society is gonna tell you that's impossible
and whatever,
but it's not,
it's not impossible
and it's 100% doable.
And again, everyone's situation is different.
So I don't wanna,
I don't wanna say like, oh,
this works for everyone,
but I feel like
for most people that think you're so lucky,
you're so this,
you're so that
you can do that,
you can do it too.
And you just have to sacrifice
and go look at your cost.
Go look at what you can cut down on.
Your kids don't need a fancy house,
they don't need a brand New car.
Like, they're not gonna remember those things,
but they're gonna remember you.
That you were there every,
every single day,
every step of the way.
You didn't miss a milestone.
They're gonna remember that.
And before you twist my words,
this is not shaming any other moms out there.
Um, because in one situation is different,
and, you know,
you know what's best.
But this is just my opinion on the subject,
because I'm just
honestly so tired of people constantly saying,
you're so privileged.
Like, if we were walking around with, like,
rich husbands and, like,
all this stuff,
like, no, ma'am,
we sacrifice,
were determined,
and we want to give our kids the best life.